framework for expressing yourself in a  way that helps you get heard and helps  you speak in a way that really expresses  what's going on for you so the format is  when you insert a specific thing that  happened I felt and you have to use an  emotion word so it can't be something  that's judging them like I felt left  behind it would be something like I felt  sad I felt enraged I felt depressed  whatever it was because of my need for  blank so you explain to them why this  matters so recently I had this in a work  conversation where I said when I wasn't  part of that decision making it made me  feel sad because of my need for  inclusion and then you say in the future  I request that you blank and you say a  specific request that they can agree to  or talk to you about